Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Um,
May 20th.
Yeah,
May 20th kip people keep it going from May 20th.
Come on.
Isn't she lovely?
May 20th,
2013 on the other.
How are Ya,
you don't want to right there.
Huh?
You do want to write with the twinkle toes?
Um,
I'm kind of in a fucked up mood.
Why?
We just got back.
I was on the road,
the lovely Nia for the last fucking 10 days and I was really nervous about that.
The whole thing,
like 10 straight days,
24 fucking seven,
basically.
Other than when I was on stage running my Goddamn Yep.
She was going to be a,
at my side,
I was like a,
you know,
this is going to be bad.
We only had one,
one major fight,
one major.
Like go fuck yourself.
I'm going to go become a sea captain.
You'll be Google being astronauts.
So we could be as far away from each other as possible and only at one of those
only had one.
Um,
so we just got back to California and we'd know taped all these shows and shit,
and she was watching one and they just showed some fucking jog.
Some jogger got mauled to death by a pack of pit bulls.
So then I look up the story and it says it has been like five deadly attacks by
dogs in California in the last whatever year,
year and a half.
And all of them were pit bulls.
Okay.
So I go to Nia,
I go,
you know,
what exactly do we have on our hands here?
And she's like,
well,
I think there were different kinds of owners.
And I said,
okay,
ah,
fuck me.
What do I do?
What do you do when you're in love with a monster?
No,
it's not a monster.
It can be.
It's kind of like a gun in the wrong hands.
Is that what it is?
I don't know what it is,
but it fucking really made me,
they'd be nervous.
Really fucking made me nervous.
It's kind of a creepy way to start the podcast,
isn't it?
I usually come on,
I sing a song or something.
Right?
The summerwind little Vegas action came,
blow it in from across the sea.
You wore Nike flip flops with dark black socks down to the casino floor.
But since the mob has left and it's a bunch of corporate cons,
you can get away with that Fashion Shit Bato bought are bought up a dope.
I don't like your white trash tattooed flabby arms.
Sorry,
I was just singing about what you seen.
You know people who go to Vegas.
Can you do me a favor?
Can you dress up a little bit?
You fucking pieces of shit.
Any I was going to say and you know who you are.
All right.
They don't know who they are.
These fucking guys who come downstairs like a Basketball Jersey on right?
No fucking shirt underneath it.
Sitting there looking at the,
the,
the beginning or ending depending on which way you're looking at their back of
their back acne.
You know they got the shoulder zits shorts,
right?
Flip flops,
dark fucking black socks.
Just standing there.
I mean,
you know,
back in the day when the mob ran it,
if you didn't come downstairs with a college shirt on looking like a God damn
adult,
they sent you back to your room and they said,
hey look,
I'm make smitten with you.
Say get it out.
And he can't get no fucking right.
They sent you back to your fucking room and you came down.
All right looking like a gentlemen.
Ladies looked like ladies in the who is dressed like who was all right and if
you were some fucking piece of shit,
they just throw you out.
You know,
how much money do we need to make?
Do we need to make so much fucking money?
We were going to allow this fucking jerk off to be standing there like this.
It was unbelievable.
You know,
everybody,
you know,
it's just eat.
There was so many people dress nicely,
ah fuck,
don't do this to me.
Sorry,
little technical difficulties here.
There was so many people dress nicely and all it takes is just somebody like
that to just ruin the family photo and actually took a picture of his flip flops
and his dark socks.
You know what the funny thing was is the horror that was from the ankles down on
this guy actually match the casino rug quite nicely.
I might add,
I don't know if you guys have been to a lot of casinos,
but there's some unwritten rule rule that they have to have zany carpeting.
You know,
I don't know if it puts you in a more festive mood as you're losing all your
fucking money.
I don't know what it is,
but every one of those casinos,
not one of them just has a nice solid color,
you know,
an electric blue,
a red cap,
whatever,
an earth tone.
None of them,
it's this confetti.
It's like they took all the yarn that was leftover at a factory and they just
sewed the shit together.
I Dunno.
I don't know.
Other than that I had a great time in Vegas other than when I went down to the
pool because I go down to the pool,
I'm down there to me,
it's fucking j law head who's been killing it in front of me.
And uh,
the lovely Nia and her cousins and we're hanging earning cousin.
I mean,
and we're hanging out down the pool and they're doing the usual shit,
you know,
if you're a red head and he'd go down to the pool like you just asking him for
it.
People that all,
look how white you are.
You know?
Like,
I never noticed.
It's like I'm fucking around myself.
I've been around myself since the sixties,
the late sixties.
I know how white I am and if I ever forget how white I am,
there's always somebody there to remind me.
Sorry,
I don't know if you've noticed your skin tone.
What am I meditating?
Floating up out of my body.
All right,
so these people are with doe on,
C'mon on in the pool and like,
I don't want to go on the pool.
I don't want to go on the fucking pool.
You know,
they're like,
why?
No,
why don't you want to go to the pool?
You know why?
Because the fucking,
yeah,
look at,
look at these people,
look at them,
look at them.
And you're get,
you're getting your,
you know,
would you take a bath with all,
with any one of the people that you see here,
these fucking just masses of human beings.
There's not enough chlorine and a fucking pool to kill whatever the fuck they're
dragging in the pool.
You know,
it was like I finally end up going into the pool.
Then everybody made fun of how white my fucking alabaster chest was a da that I
had to stay in the shade of the fucking,
uh,
the lifeguard's chair,
you know,
I had a show to do,
I'm being a professional,
I can't come out stage later,
half in the bag looking like,
oh,
right.
I got to do my little song and dance later on that night.
So,
anyway,
so I ended up getting in the fucking pool against my,
what I wanted to do,
you know?
And then I get out of the pool.
First of all for my age,
I am an absolutely phenomenal top shelf shape.
All right,
I got to tell you the fucking,
just the deaf fuck the humanity that I saw poolside in Las Vegas,
the fucking humanity.
Okay.
Keyword manatee.
Not this gap step on a Jim Gaffigan.
I just realized he used to use that reference and I'm pretty sure he used it.
I can't remember how the fuck he used it,
but if he used it to describe a fat Pale Torso,
not really pale board or whatever the fucking shit.
I saw the side of that.
He was dead on that.
Oh my God.
Is there anything worse than seeing a tattoo come of age?
You know?
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
If you get a tattoo,
you better.
You better just make the mental decision that you're going to [inaudible] for
the rest of your fucking life.
Cause when you don't do it,
I saw this guy down at the pool.
All right,
okay.
He had like not only the worst tattoo you've ever seen in your life,
like the worst placement,
you know what I mean?
Like you get one like on the side of your arm up by your shoulder,
that looks good,
right on the bicep.
That looks good.
You know Joe,
somebody got gets one right over there.
Voicebox like I don't give a fuck what you have surrounding that.
That leads into that part of the,
of the,
of the work or the piece,
whatever they call it.
It looks fucking horrible.
Leg Tattoos,
horrific,
horrific.
So this fucking jerk off.
He has basically the exact sorta like tribal thing that the rock has except he
doesn't look tribal.
He looks like an accountant,
you know,
and he doesn't work out.
So just imagine if the rock was as pasty as I was
and it never worked down in his life.
But he has that same tattoo that starts at the elbow,
goes up the arm,
over the shoulder and covers one whole peck.
But the way this guy had it done was it didn't cover his whole packet came
swinging in and went right above his,
his men nipple.
So now all of the,
all of that is like colored in.
So because of the pace,
enos of his torso,
your eye is just drawn to his right nipple.
Is he standing in the fucking pool?
My neck was sore from shaking my head at people.
It was,
it was absolutely fucking horrific,
right?
So,
so anyways,
um,
I go back up to the,
uh,
I go back up to the hotel room,
right?
You know,
gotta make sure that I'm all shipshape for my God damn show and I put on the
news and what are they ended up doing a story about,
they start doing a story about the amount of,
uh,
fecal matter found in public pools
right after I just got out of a God damn pool.
You know?
And I know people always think,
oh,
stay away from where the kids are.
Stay away from the Kiddie Pool.
Right?
Stay away from there.
They always blame the fucking kids.
Will I,
you know something after seeing what I saw a poolside,
you know,
there weren't a lot of kids in there,
but I guarantee you somebody's got a cola.
I know this is fucking disgusting.
But people you've,
you're basically bathing,
you know what's even more fucked up.
His,
his Vegas is just like,
you know,
people fly in from all over the world.
You're taking a fucking aids bath,
you know,
with a shot of fucking,
uh,
what the hell was that shit that came out,
but it killed people so fast that it just burned out.
Everybody just ran into the woods.
The fuck was that shit cold.
Ah,
Christ,
they can't remember a bola.
That's it with a shot of a bola or whatever.
Food poisoning.
I don't know what it is.
A salmon,
Ella shower,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
I'm done with public pools.
The only pool that I will ever swim in again is my pool.
If I ever get one or the pool of some hot chick that I want to fucking bank
cause I have needs permission,
that's the only way it's going to go down.
Other than that,
you know,
I'll just go,
I'll just go take a bath.
That way I'm out of the sun,
you know,
take a couple of vitamin E pills,
whatever the fuck it is you get from the sun.
Other than skin cancer,
I'm done with it.
You know what America needs to implement after years and years of calling the
French people smelly.
You know?
That's kind of like the thing when we went over to France and saved their ass
for the second time last century.
Oh wait,
did we do it once?
We did it one time,
right?
I can't fucking remember.
You know,
I thought the Spanish American war took place in Texas.
I thought it was somehow tied in with the Alamo.
I had no fucking idea.
You know why?
Because they never talked about it.
All I talked about was a revolutionary war.
We got right up to about the war of 1812 and that was it.
French and Indian war and then they just stopped.
Yeah.
You know,
they never,
they never did anything be a civil war we talked about,
but that was it.
Spanish American war as far as what I remember from Wikipedia took place in
like,
I don't know,
Cuba,
Puerto Rico and like Guam.
Figure that one out
some point.
Uh,
you know,
that's one of those books like if I ever have insomnia,
I'm just going to start reading the history of the Spanish American war.
You know,
I didn't realize it was an away game.
I thought that that was in our building.
Evidently it wasn't,
and it was spread out all over hail.
So anyways,
we've always made fun of the French file.
This they smell.
If you ever watched a bugs bunny growing up,
man,
you saw pepe Le Pew.
If you noticed he had a French accent,
you know,
that's the kind of shit you couldn't get away with today because of political
correctness.
I guess they were basically saying that you know that they stuck.
But I'll tell you one thing that the French have when it comes to hygiene over
Americans.
All right?
Is the big day.
I can guarantee you if I ever go swimming in a public pool again,
it's going to be at Fred's Ellis
is a bunch of Americans.
I know.
I've been over to England.
I never saw it,
but day over there,
you know,
but day is basically a car wash for your asshole Ed.
Uh,
you know,
it leaves you feeling refreshed,
puts a fucking smile on your face and evidently had France.
She's so fucking happy.
You forget to put on deodorant,
but I'll tell you right now,
you can jump in that pool.
I bet they're not dead,
but they're not talking about that shit over there,
right?
You,
what's funny about this?
I am 15 minutes into this podcast.
I just told a 15 minutes,
shit joke.
Do you realize that?
And that can mean only one thing.
It's time for some advertising.
And when we come back from advertising,
everybody,
this is what they call in the business.
A teaser.
Um,
if I can figure out how you use this tablet,
oh,
fuck you.
Who's this?
Okay,
I don't want to hear it.
I don't want to hear what whoever the fuck that to get to the library to.
Oh,
when you come back from the break,
um,
I'm going to tell you about meeting Pete rose.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
we'll do all stamps.com everybody.
You know what?
You live it.
You love it.
If you're not on board yet,
I don't know what your problem is.
All right.
You must just,
you must have a crush on somebody who works at the post office.
That's the only thing I can think of.
You know?
Is that what it is?
You love this smell of envelopes.
I don't,
other than that,
I don't know why you're going to the post office.
Okay.
Because why?
There's nothing instant about getting posted from the post office driving their
parking.
It's a waste of time.
So you stamps.com instead,
instantly get posted for any letter or package right from your desk.
A stamps.com is so quick and easy to use.
You can buy and print official US postage using your own computer and Printer
Stan stopped stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact postage you need.
They'll even help you decide the best class of mail based on your needs.
Not My needs.
Your needs.
Oh,
Steve Jobs.
Stop it with this iPhone here.
Sorry about that.
Anyways,
there's no guesswork.
Plus,
it's convenient.
Take care of your mailing and shipping whenever you need to.
24 seven right from your desk.
You'll never have to go to the post post office again or do it from the comfort
of your own home like I do.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs.
I've never had a problem.
I absolutely loved it.
I hated going to the post office.
I've never been happier when it comes to male.
Right now,
use my last name burpee.
You IRR for this special offer.
No risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage.
A don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstancestamps.com
enter burr.
Um,
what else do I got to know?
Jesus.
Where's Whiz?
I got to go to he voice.
Now I'm using a tablet for the first time.
Everybody,
here we go.
He voice the voice is the reason you're gonna make more money in 2013.
You know you thought you were going to rob a bank.
No reason to do that.
Just start using a voice and you will make more money in 2013 when your
customers call you have your own toll free number,
profess professional greeting,
dial by name directory and more.
You'll sound like a fortune 500 company and blow away your competitors' Eve
void.
Lets you get it.
Give out one number that rings wherever you are.
The beach,
the bar,
doesn't matter.
You'll sound like you're at the office.
You got to go to [inaudible] dot com and use the Promo Code Bill.
He voice even takes all your voicemails,
transcribes them,
and sends the sends to you in and transcribes them and sends to you instantly as
a text or email.
Sorry.
So you can eat voice so you can check ie voicemails before the meeting ends and
not look rude.
He voices only 10 bucks a month.
Right now.
Listeners to my podcast can get a free trial of he voice for 30 days.
Stop what you're doing.
Hit Pause,
set up your eve voice free trial and see what I'm talking about.
It's a great way to support my podcasts,
my podcast,
and an easy way to make more money this year.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
That's [inaudible] dot com promo code bill,
or just go to the podcast page on bill bird dot clomp com and click the voice
banner right now.
All right,
good Lord.
I have like,
I just really have issues with reading out loud some weeks.
Yes,
some weeks because I've been doing better recently.
Okay.
And I know you console going to give me shit.
Ooh,
Ooh.
So we'd sue who do boat every week,
lol,
shaking my head.
Oh,
here's another thing for Twitter hack.
When people,
when people begin to joke with in other news,
you know,
that weekend update staple from 1986 on SNL,
blah,
blah.
Blue.
The doodle,
do the doe in other news,
the little bit of a Ba.
All right,
that's your joke,
right in class.
That's probably the worst description ever.
I go fuck yourself.
So anyway,
so I'm walking back to the hotel and I walked by this sports members back in
Vegas,
by the way.
All right.
Okay.
Are you with me?
We're out of the shit pool.
And now I'm walking through the little mall there and I see this sports
memorabilia place and I see Pete rose is going to be there.
Like the guy's going to be here in an hour.
I'm like,
I gotta meet this fucking guy that's fucking Pete rose.
And I'm looking at all the baseballs.
He signs.
It's hilarious.
She signs it hits,
uh,
like 4,000,
256 steroids.
Zero.
Pete rose hit king.
I thought that was the shit.
Um,
so anyways,
I'd seen him signing there before and the line was too long and I didn't feel
like waiting.
So this time me and lie head who doesn't an amazing impression of him breaking
ty cobb's record the entire thing.
Him Standing on first base hit to hitting the ball,
standing on first place,
waving to the crowd,
gradually trying to fight off tears,
hugging his son and breaking down.
He does the whole fucking thing.
He does it at the rose bowl after cooking a delicious meal.
But anyway,
so I'm hanging out with Tim and you can add,
you buy all this memorabilia and Pete Rose,
we'll uh,
we'll sign it for you.
So they had two photos
and one was Pete rose,
like sliding headfirst into third base and the 1975 world series when he beat my
Boston red sox.
And another photo that I saw in the collection was Pete rose in the 1976 world
series where they beat the Yankees once again,
sliding headfirst into third base batting helmet.
What?
Who knows where it went?
It always flew off.
It seemed between first and second base.
Um,
so I'm like,
oh my God,
that's perfect.
I gotta get,
I gotta get both of those,
right.
So my whole thing is I want them to write on the Red Sox won bill,
I'm sorry,
Pete rose.
And then on the Yankee one bill,
you're welcome,
Pete Rose,
right?
So bring it up to him.
Great Guy.
Hey,
how you doing?
And all that type of thing.
So I tell him,
I go,
okay,
I go on big red sox fan.
This is you beating the red sox as you're beating the Yankees.
So John,
this one just right,
bill,
I'm sorry.
Any immediately looks at me.
And he goes,
I'm not
a fucking died laughing.
I loved that he still had that competitive thing,
you know?
And I was like,
I know you're not.
I go say you're not,
that's funny or whatever.
And he didn't,
he still wrote it and then just right.
You know,
you know you're welcome on the other one.
And he actually wrote,
uh,
wrote bill,
I'm sorry,
on one,
Eh,
Pete Rose,
1975 world series MVP.
And on the other one,
he wrote,
uh,
Bill,
you're welcome,
Pete rose.
And then he wrote reds for Yankee zero,
something about a sweep or something like that.
In fact,
when I brought up the Yankees,
I said,
yeah,
but you beat the Yankees in 1976.
He goes and he immediately goes,
swept their asses.
It's fucking great.
Um,
so anyways,
I got to meet him and get shot the shit with them for a second,
shot the shit with the greatest hitter of all time.
You know,
I asked him who was a,
who's the toughest guy you've ever faced?
All right,
I'm going to pause here.
You're going to guess.
Who Do you think it was?
A guy from the 60s.
Who Do you think?
Okay.
Hi.
What are you guessing?
Bob Gibson.
It's a good guest.
Don Drysdale.
Now the good guests.
Steve Cowen,
who was actually Sandy Colfax.
How's that?
Really?
Sandy Colfax.
And then he made this motion of like the ball just fucking dropping off a cliff.
He did it with both hands.
Like the guy could get a break in either way.
And uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
I actually talked to about the red sox.
He actually like still watches baseball.
He's totally fucking into it.
And,
uh,
I think at first he taught me and Jay were a couple of creeps,
said he could tell that we really looked up to him and wanted to talk baseball
and he was fucking,
you know,
just totally warmed up,
man.
Cool as hell.
So if you ever get a chance and don't be a cunt,
like that little weasel that brought that shit up.
All right.
Everybody knows he'd been on baseball enough already.
You know,
they didn't let him into the hall of fame.
He cited memorabilia at a casino.
We ease,
pay the price.
You know,
you realize how small that is.
Like they actually get a baseball there.
It was all in black that he signs.
I'm sorry.
I bet on baseball Pete rose.
And I'm just like,
ugh.
Jesus Christ.
You bring that ball up to him.
Kind of fucking asshole would do that.
Oh,
who's kidding?
Who half the people on Twitter?
Um,
anyways.
Oh,
you know what?
Fucking blows it doesn't blow.
It was actually an awesome sporting,
uh,
experience.
But,
uh,
I don't know,
some of you guys who follow me on Twitter or whatever.
Last week I was in Boston and,
uh,
I'm,
if you listen to last week's podcast,
I mentioned that I was going through that Bruins,
maple leaf's game seven.
And uh,
I did get in,
I was there,
I went with this comedian Doug sin.
Yay.
Boston gay came up from up from New York and went to the game.
I had a good feeling,
I thought we were going to win it.
And uh,
I gotta be honest with you,
you know,
we look good for the first two minutes and then all of a sudden it was all leafs
after that.
And at three to one
I was convinced we were going to lose.
So I'm like,
God,
that's it.
That's it.
We score two goals.
That's our limit.
They just scored the third,
you know,
the leafs of playing great hockey,
they totally got this game in hand.
So,
you know,
and then they went up four to one and that's when the first like wave a Bruins
fans started leaving like seven,
eight minutes left.
I forget what happened.
And like people were leaving and leaf fans,
we'll move on down.
All right now it's not like I'm sitting there going,
you know,
I gave him shit for leaving.
I was yelling where you go,
what the fuck?
But my shit was more,
we have to stay because I hate when the other team's fans take over your
building,
you know what I mean?
And get to celebrate and kind of fucking dance in your living room.
So after three to one,
I was convinced we were going to lose.
So,
but the only reason why I was still there was because I was there to basically
give maple leaf fans dirty look when they beat us.
So they'd have to tone down this celebration and also to give a bad description
to the cops if somebody threw something at them,
you know,
unless it was something major and really hurt him.
Um,
so that's it.
So I'd like to thank my mother for teaching me to never leave.
You'll always stay.
You now believe that game until it's over.
And we stayed there and all of a sudden it was 42 who Cheech score then on it
was four to three,
four to four fucking place was going insane.
And I was actually nervous that um,
you know,
and the regulation that was given Toronto a time to regroup,
almost like when you're in a fight,
you know,
you see a fighter and he's got the guy in the ropes and all of a sudden saved by
the bell.
I almost felt like it was like that and I just had this,
I hate this gnawing feeling that they would have come out and score a quick one
and all that excitement would have been for nothing.
But fortunately a burger on scored.
And I have to tell you,
as far as sporting events that I've ever been to,
that one is a close second to a,
I went to the Superbowl when the Patriots beat the Rams for our first super bowl
championship and it was unbelievable.
My condolences to the leaf fans,
man.
I think you guys are fucking awesome fans and a,
I wouldn't wish what happened to you on anybody other than Montreal.
Canadien fans for the simple fact that they fucking deserve it.
Uh,
you know what's funny though?
Leaf fans are really hated.
They're really hate it.
I don't know why.
I've never understood that.
Like how you can like have that level of no championships.
I mean they're,
they're,
they're going on 46 years,
so it's 47 seasons.
They coming up on 50 fucking years,
a half a century and not winning shit.
And people still hate him.
I don't know why.
I don't,
you know,
I'm going to have to ask some Canadian people what the fucking deal is with that
because I would think that they would hate Montreal fans more.
But it seems like,
I dunno,
I was surprised.
Maybe they do eight Montreal fans more,
I don't know.
But I was surprised at the level of hatred,
like the emails that I was getting from other Canadians about how much they hate
fucking Toronto leaf,
make maple leaf fans,
the ones that came to the fleet center.
We're cool as hell,
you know,
and uh,
so whatever.
So now we're into the next round and the fucking bro A's
go Bob Bob.
That's what it used to be.
They'd have to fucking,
the Rangers won in 1994 and that let's go.
Rangers became so iconic that uh,
that that fucking rhythm took over everything.
So now whenever people go,
let's go bro wins.
I can never fully give my heart into that fucking uh,
that chant.
Cause I'm always thinking that's the rangers chant.
We were always,
here we go Bruins,
here we go.
They were always let's go rangers.
But like that whole writ,
that toe cadence has taken over everything,
which the funniest one is his Yankee fence cause they used to go 1918 and then
when that was over,
they,
for some reason you needed four syllables.
They went,
they took a fourth syllable chant and they try to cram them in a long gate.
The third day they basically,
they went from 1918 to Boston sucks,
but they kept the same rhythm so they go,
Boston sucks.
Oh those fucking hero Eaton Jackass is,
um,
why would you be like,
Fuck you Boston?
I mean something that fit,
you know why?
Because they're not that smart.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
But anyway,
you always were the best thing about fucking being back in Boston.
Cause I watched the,
uh,
I watch a red sox game,
went out to get some pizza and I just walk.
I mean he just was so fucking nice.
This is the biggest thing I miss about living in Massachusetts is just walking
into a sports bar or a fucking pizza place in the game I want to watch is on and
everybody in there is for the team that I like.
I moved away from Boston in 1995 and it's like I've been behind enemy lines here
coming up on 20 fucking years and I'm exhausted.
I'm like,
I've said this before in the podcast.
I'm like a sports,
like Donnie Brasco,
you know,
so he sent me a fucking tweet today.
They go,
hey bill,
now that you live in La,
uh,
are you a kings fan now or do you still have loyalty to the Bruins?
And I,
that is,
I can't even relate to that fucking question.
That's such a dumb question.
I don't understand how people,
how you root for a team your whole fucking life,
and then you move somewhere else you'd like,
well,
I guess I'll root for these guys now.
You know,
I don't hate the kings.
I mean,
they sucked my whole life coming up.
So we never ran into him.
We always ran to the Edmonton Oilers as far as people out west,
they used to fucking kick our ass.
So,
uh,
but even then,
I didn't hate him.
They hated the Canadians.
Hated the sabers.
I hated Hatford
the dig site in mind for some reason,
but that was the atoms division back then.
So I really didn't like them.
I didn't like the devils.
Fucking island were always tough islanders with tough Jesus.
They were tough back then in the early eighties.
Obviously they want a middle of a fucking dynasty.
So,
um,
yeah,
so the person who asks me that,
I don't hate the,
uh,
I'm not a fan.
I'm actually a fan.
Like I liked the way they play.
I like their,
they're a franchise the same way.
I like,
you know,
I am a fan of like the devil rays or something like that.
But,
uh,
until they,
they didn't let people say devil anymore,
you know,
like Tampa needed another reason to make funny fun of them.
You know what I mean?
I think the name Maria Baseball teams to evil.
I don't mind the fish part.
Put the other part.
I just,
I just don't like,
I don't eat devil's food cake and I love dessert.
Um,
you know,
reminds me of last night.
Oh,
big.
First of all,
big thank you to,
uh,
the Mirage casino for having me out there.
Um,
and everybody who showed up,
I had so much fun.
The two shows that I did out there and they had me,
you know,
I took a picture of it and I know you guys are going to shit all over me.
You guys always figuring out how to fucking way to shit all over me.
But I don't give a fuck.
It was a big moment in my life.
So I'm up on one of those main mark.
He's out there.
They don't want a big stupid fucking red head right up there.
You know,
it was fucking awesome.
I was playing this theater and um,
it was great.
It was packed.
Both shows,
signed some DVDs,
took some pictures,
had a great fucking time.
You know,
you know what I did?
I only gambled once.
I bet on the Preakness I came down,
I was watching the penguins,
um,
senators game the one we're fucking Crosby had the hat trick right out of the
gate.
And uh,
I'll sit in there with law head,
you know,
nursing a beer because I had a show that night and I'm watching it and in front
of us,
these guys were betting the horses and I gotta tell you something.
There's no gamblers are funnier than people who bet the fucking horse has been.
They are hilarious.
They get so fucking into it.
Is that coming down the home stretch?
I stopped watching the hockey game.
The hockey game was on the giant one.
They're watching it on these little screens and like these fucking degenerate
gambling cubicles and they got their rolled up programs and they hitting the
table.
Just go,
come on,
come on your six head up.
I don't see it.
They,
they literally go to the hospital.
God,
you six car,
you sex,
God,
you said God,
you say hi.
It's just a head up.
Head Up.
This fucking guy yelled in the casino.
Beat that horse.
You got to stand up living out here.
Right and fucking Tinseltown most liberal place ever.
All right.
Peter has a Goddamn parade out every fucking three seconds.
So just to hear that beat that horse,
I was fucking dying laughing.
Even though I love horses and if I ever owned one,
my dreams don't a horse and never ride it.
You know,
keep that fuck a pure,
I don't ever want to break it.
So it allows me to get on.
It's fucking back.
My stupid booze weight sitting on his back is,
it walks me up the hill,
even though if it wanted to,
it could just kick me with its back foot knocked me out forever.
There's something sad about that.
So anyways,
so I go down there the next day would lie ahead.
So we put money on the Preakness EFIC.
I can remember though,
fuck I even
one of the horses we bet wasn't in the rate,
wasn't in the race from fucking the second it started.
And then my other going,
I bet was it horse numbers wasn't three something with golden it,
I can't fucking remember.
It was in second place until they came around the clubhouse turning and that was
it.
Uh,
but the fucking place was jam packed and people were going crazy for like a
minute and a half or whatever it is.
It's just,
they go nuts the second they're let out and then that dies down.
And then the coming around the first turn,
there's this Marmot,
you go,
there you go,
get on a rail going on around,
you know,
and then this is it.
Calming down the back,
stretch that fucking shit when they come down and down and stretch that cub,
the place is going fucking crazy.
And everybody's screaming.
There was this one guy,
I watched him,
he lost six races in a fucking row.
So,
and I didn't bet any of the racist.
This guy was like the,
the,
the mush in a Bronx tale.
And I'm looking at it,
he's the guy who yelled,
beat that horse,
right?
So I'm looking at him,
cause I bet the Preakness and I see him and his family sitting behind me and
he's got this big shitty grin on his face and I bet I think horse number three
in horse number eight.
And he's got this big shitty grin on his face.
And he turned around and he looks basically over my head.
He looks back at his family and he holds up number seven and he's smiling and
nodding.
I'm thinking,
right,
go,
well that fucking horse isn't winning.
He said three or rate,
I swear to God,
if I had any backbone and would have up my ticket,
like fucking Chazz Palminteri and just go home guys.
It's over.
Um,
so anyways,
so let's,
let's get on to fucking read and something for this week.
I had a really
interesting email from somebody.
I don't know how to,
uh,
I really don't know how to,
what the hell is,
this is going to be brutal this week.
Cause you know what?
These guys are finally working on my house and I don't have Internet because the
room that they did,
they fucking Yank the thing out of the wall.
All right,
here we go.
Helping an ugly friend.
Do you have an ugly French shirt?
We all do.
Here we go.
Dear billion.
Birr um,
thanks for doing the podcast,
but he'd be DPTP thank you.
Um,
what am I good friends is ugly.
I'll say it outright.
God bless his heart.
He's 26 short,
disproportionate face.
I don't know what that means.
A skinny with a gut.
Slowly forming.
Oh God.
Receding hairline,
Jesus.
And worst of all,
he doesn't take care of his teeth.
Eh,
wow.
Jesus fucking Christ all I thought if there was Clint Howard,
um,
over the past couple of years he's gotten more and more bitter about life.
I believe it's dude who's insecurity about his looks and attracting women.
He has a great degree,
really well paying job,
good sense of humor and can talk to the ladies.
However he lacks the killer instinct needed to close the deal.
Meaning he gets friend zoned with every girl that is possibly interested,
which is very few.
Well,
he kind of talking out of both sides of your mouth.
You're saying he's great with the women,
but he just can't close the deal.
Why there are only a few women interested in them.
What are you going to say?
See the first paragraph where you decide to fuck.
You basically described a troll.
Um,
myself and close friends have been subtly pushing him to work out,
clean his teeth,
eat healthily,
healthy,
et cetera.
But he gets very offended whenever we suggest anything.
He seems to be set on a path of thinking he's going to have to wait until his
forties before women will be desperate enough to ignore his looks and data for a
successful career.
Uh,
this type of attitude is starting to affect his friendships.
He's getting bitter and defensive,
bitter,
defensive and confrontational.
Nobody likes an angry troll.
They really don't.
Okay.
If you're going to go the troll route,
you know,
you got,
you gotta be at the very least affable.
You don't work your way towards jolly.
I would think maybe you can put on a silly hat,
build some toys,
I dunno.
Um,
as his friend,
how can I help them get off this path and boost his confidence to get that
killer instinct and confidence that the ladies love,
even if you're,
even if you're ugly,
thanks for the advice and go fuck yourself.
Uh,
bs.
Shout out to the beautiful city of Boston.
I was there last year for a hockey tournament and can't wait to go back.
He s s fuck,
he ruins.
I've lost two years of my life.
Do the stress of the maple leaf series.
Oh Jesus.
God.
Must have sent that before it was over.
Um,
all right,
so what do you say to this guy?
Oh Wow.
Well,
I don't know him,
but at some point you just going to have to fucking lay it on the line
and say it to them and say like,
look,
you know something?
Yeah,
just like me.
All right.
You want to have fun,
you want to go.
So your oats is,
they say,
and then you want to find love and get married and start a family.
Correct.
You know
he got to brush your fucking teeth.
I don't know how to,
how do you go into it?
Slowly like this is no matter how you come at,
it's when somebody is defensive,
this is,
there's no way to come at them without burning up in the atmosphere of their
fucking bitterness during reentry.
How do you do it?
I would wait till the next time he says something bitter or defensive or
something like that and just look at them and be like,
listen dude,
you're your own worst enemy.
All right.
Life is a horse race and you're shooting yours in the back of the head before
the fucking gate even opens.
Then you walk around the track with mud on your shoes.
You know,
wonder why a,
I don't know why you fucking some other horse racing thing that I don't know
shit about.
I picked the wrong metaphor.
You know what?
I may just wait til he's being a cunt.
I remember one time I,
I knew this guy,
he was just negative as fucking hell and you'd say,
Hey,
you know something,
if you keep doing this,
maybe this will happen.
And then he always be like,
yeah,
you know,
with my luck,
the fucking piano fall on my head and I got sick of it.
And then finally I'd be like,
yeah,
you know.
Well,
you know,
if you think that way,
that's probably gonna happen.
And only said at one time.
And he never talked that way again.
He's still negative,
but I didn't have to deal with that shit.
I Dunno what to do with this guy.
Like,
um,
you might,
you might have to fucking channel Patrice O'neil,
God rest his soul.
Patrice O'Neal would've sat this dude down and what it said,
Edward,
what the fuck are you doing?
Look at yourself.
You know
you got a fucked up face.
You're losing your God damn hair at the very least brushed your fucking teeth.
Get some fucking better clothes.
What's wrong?
I can't do,
I can't do what he would've done.
He would've been able to do it.
He would have hurt.
The guy's feeling so bad while helping him to become a better person at the same
time.
You might,
you're going to have to come up with your own fucking version of that.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I don't know what,
what do you do when somebody just stops brushing their teeth?
Just tap it out on
humanity
and you're saying he's smart.
He has a degree.
He's not one of those reasons.
Anything worse than somebody really smart with bad fucking hygiene.
You know those people that they're so fucking smart,
they,
you know,
they show up,
they got like sleep there.
I,
Oh God.
Too bad teeth is a goddamn deal breaker.
You know
Jesus fucking Christ.
You know,
it's funny.
I'm disgusted with this guy.
Don't you teach?
You're getting your yummy fighting.
Yeah.
You just got to quit
fucking asshole.
I was born with orange hair that I quit.
I got great teeth that I ever stopped brushing.
No,
I did.
I got second and third week bars.
I without the sun.
Then I stopped flossing.
I did what?
Fucking moping around.
Who?
Ugly mother fucker.
You get yourself some skull and Listerine and a fucking scrub brush you go to.
If God damn dentist,
she gets your fucking teeth clique.
Okay.
All right.
When you hit on a woman,
you stay on it.
You keep those plates spinning.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's having a condom.
Always be ready.
Okay.
What time is it?
It's great.
Dot.
Do something like that on.
What the fuck to tell you?
That's fucking,
there's nothing that annoys me more than watching somebody just quit.
Okay.
Tell him that.
Tell him stop being such a fucking baby.
It's fucking eight year olds so together God damn shirts.
Okay.
Probably toddlers making the toothbrushes that he's not even using all poor
fucking baby.
Okay.
You know,
you don't look like John Davidson.
Who gives a fuck.
Okay.
Brush your teeth.
Shave your fucking head down.
All right.
Go to the gym.
Give yourself a fighting chance.
Stop treating yourself like you're the pirates.
You know,
running yourself like the fucking pirates do.
What did I do to this God damn thing?
Okay.
All right.
Sorry man.
I just,
I,
there's just something really fucking gets me about people who do that shit.
We just fucking quit.
Okay.
It's nothing worse than that unless you really just truly suck at something
like,
you know,
like you guys here,
I sing,
I'm terrible.
But it's funny cause it's the podcast.
But if I was actually trying to sing professionally,
that's one thing you really should quit
and fucking do something else with.
Just,
just for your fellow man,
you know?
Yeah.
But you just,
just,
uh,
just a quick,
you're going to quit.
I'm legitimately disgusted with that person I never met before.
I don't know what to tell you.
Okay.
What an asshole.
Fuck any gets bitter.
You know what?
That reminds me of some reason there was fun.
One time I was doing a show and there was somebody in the front row that was
mentally challenged.
So there's no way I'm fucking with this guy.
And then I get on stage and the kids account,
he starts fucking heckling me,
you know?
And every time I don't say anything back,
he gets a little more fucking confident and it finally,
I was just like,
you know what?
I came in with the fuck.
I said to him,
the crowd pulled back.
I'm like,
you know what?
Fuck this guy.
They're just like everybody else.
Okay?
Some of them are cunts,
and this is a great example.
So fuck you buddy.
What kind of capita?
Dad?
It was really a fight.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
I think I fucking annoyed me.
I was doing some hell Gig the first time I lived out here in l a m standards,
some fucking Mexican restaurant.
I'm getting fucking heckled by this kid.
All right?
I am.
You know what I'm doing living in La.
I'm going through that fucking bullshit.
But you know what?
I didn't quit.
I brushed my teeth before that fucking shelf
do.
When you,
when you just don't brush your teeth,
you just tapped out.
Okay?
You just say,
fuck it.
Why won't this,
wait a minute.
Why I want this thing fucking low.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You know,
you guys hear me battle on this shit every week.
Do I fucking quit this?
Okay.
Loading.
How do I make it go back?
Okay.
Ah,
I was doing so well and all I had to do was read a couple more and I was done.
What if I shut it off and then I turn it back on again?
What happened?
Jesus Christ,
I swear to God.
How do these things make you fucking life easier?
Could somebody please explain it to me?
How it makes it easier.
Oh sure.
It's easier to go shopping or find out.
You know what you're fucking neighbor jerks off too.
But other than that,
how does it make you fucking life easier for someone like me?
Hey Nia.
Okay.
Yeah,
I know she hears me.
And that's the thing that's slowly kills you in a relationship.
I know she fucking hears me and I know she hears the panic and my fucking voice
and I know she knows that I need her and she just gotta I got to hit pause.
God fucking damn it.
Hang on a second.
Every fucking week.
All right,
I'm back.
Here we go.
Ah,
Hulu plus everybody.
Um,
you've tried streaming hit shows on your PC,
on hulu.com.
Now it's time to start your free trial of exclusive content in your living room
and on your mobile devices on Hulu plus what?
Hulu plus you get a tote,
you get total control to watch thousands of shows,
wherever you want,
whenever you want.
Uh,
use Hulu plus on connected TVs,
gaming consoles,
Blu ray players,
Roku,
apple TV,
PC,
or watch from anywhere on your smartphone or tablet on demand at all times.
Jesus Christ,
I'm going to get this.
This is phenomenal.
And with Hulu plus,
you can binge on full seasons.
What's your favorite current shows?
And even full series runs of classic TV shows.
It's endless.
You series,
you know,
I usually just read these things.
This is actually impressive as hell.
They've got community,
modern family,
south back SNL,
Monday night,
raw,
the man show Jimmy Kimmel,
family guy,
and more.
Feel free to swap this out with shows on the list.
I guess it wasn't supposed to read that.
Um,
Hulu plus is only seven 99 per month,
but right now they're offering an extended free trial of Hulu plus that is only
available to podcast listeners.
Take control of your TV watching experience.
Yeah,
you don't need networks anymore.
You create your own network.
You watch it when you want,
where you want,
and on whatever the hell you want other than the back of your hand,
you're going to be good.
Go to the podcast page at [inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu plus banner
for your extended free trial or go to Hulu plus.com/bill again,
click the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com or go to
Hulu plus.com/bill.
Um,
that's phenomenal.
That is absolutely phenomenal.
I wonder if I can watch NFL NHL Games there.
Oh,
here's some of the shows available.
Downton Abbey.
It's not downtime.
The vampire diaries,
the game new girl.
I was on that.
The office glee,
the Mindy project,
parks and rec late night with Jimmy Fallon.
Wow.
They got everything.
You know what?
That's pretty.
That's pretty damn cool.
I like it.
All right,
next thing here.
Uh,
what do we got?
Legal zoom.com everybody.
America was built by innovators and dreamers.
People like Edison,
Henry Ford,
and Steve Jobs.
But it's the inventors and entrepreneurs all around us.
People like,
you know what?
Fuck that I'm,
I'm doing a different read.
I'm not saying Steve Jobs.
I'm not saying it all right.
I'm sick of this guy getting credit like he fucking did everything.
Oh my God.
These baby boomers is so obnoxious.
Let's start over again.
legalzoom.com legalzoom.com America was built.
America was built by innovators and dreamers.
People like Edison,
Henry Ford,
and Albert Einstein.
But it's the inventors and entrepreneurs all around us.
People like you that make it make America Bill Gates.
Make America is such a great country,
Aaron spelling this month,
legal zoom celebrates innovations by helping you launch your dream.
Apply for a patent to secure your invention.
Register your trademark to protect your products and services.
Incorporate or form an LLC and launch your business dream.
Um,
just call or visit legal zoom.com and they'll take care of you from start to
finish.
They've already helped about a million businesses get started and they got them
started right.
Uh,
celebrate innovation with legal zoom.com and for a limited time,
get a special price on trademark,
copyright and patent applications by using the referral code [inaudible] at
checkout.
Protect your creations and launch your dream@legalzoom.com.
Legal Zoom can provide self help services at your specific direction or they can
connect you to an attorney,
but they are not a law firm.
Don't forget to use that referral code bur bur are all right.
There we go back to the podcast yet.
Bap,
bap,
bap boo boo.
All right,
experience with the threesome.
firstly,
congrats to the pod kids.
Let me ship.
Alright,
um,
anyways,
in a recent podcast you mentioned the guy who wants to bang another chick in
front of his wife.
Then you asked if someone's got some good stories.
No,
no,
no.
She wanted him to do it.
Oh,
by the way,
somebody else gave me a great insight to that,
which was a,
that his wife or girlfriend did the same thing,
said she wanted to see him have sex with another woman and it turned out that
she was trying to lessen her guilt cause she already fucked around on them.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's a tangled web being weaved here
now did the pussy is,
um,
after countless efforts of hitting on this,
after countless efforts of hitting on this chicken,
my class,
I found out that she was in,
she was engaged.
So I gave it arrest not long after she started hinting sexual stuff all the
time.
Getting a little too comfortable with the touching.
I bet a moron was shit like this and fuck myself over to bank.
Some random chick who turns out to be a cycle at least a couple of times.
Oh,
so you're sitting there going,
I think this girl's giving me sexual vibes,
but uh,
I don't want to be an idiot and shit where I eat.
Is that what you're saying?
Well,
you're not here to tell me either way,
so that's what I'm going to think.
So anyways,
he goes,
I started to question her about her man and what she really wants if she's just
being a tease.
Um,
she said she suggested to her fiance to have a threesome with another chick from
class.
Now she wants the two dude type of deal,
tag teaming,
double penetration of whatever else you want to call it to it right there.
That's not your wife.
Okay.
That is a free fucking spirit.
You Bang her and then you hand her backpack and you let her continue walking
down the road with that little Saucepan,
clink,
clean the pots and pans,
clicking off the back.
Anyways,
he goes,
I can't say it was comfortable,
so I had to lay some ground rules,
no eye contact between the guys,
no sword crossing,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Dude,
I gotta tell you something that what is in it for the,
as a guy to have a fucking two on one with another dude.
Although I know,
I know one guy who I actually understood it because they would be doing the
rotisserie with some girl and they would,
well,
you know,
and she can't look at them obviously because she's busy and what they would do
is they would try to make each other
laugh.
That to me that,
that,
that's fucking hilarious.
Um,
and unless you're the woman,
you never want to hear somebody just go in the middle of fucking having sex with
you,
I guess.
Um,
are you loving
about a week later,
let's get back to the thing here.
About a week later,
chicken invited me,
um,
to the house.
I'm sorry,
I'm having more trouble than usual reading this.
I keep touching this fucking tablet thing.
Hair and shit just keeps popping up.
I don't know how to get rid of it.
All right.
I think we're back to normal here.
So he goes about a week later,
the chicken invited me to the house to prepare a presentation and asked the dude
if he was okay with everything that happened.
He said,
well,
she let me have it with another chick.
So it's totally fair.
Oh,
okay.
So you guys haven't done it yet.
Okay.
So did you guys come in there and dressed in like power suits with like a
fucking little briefcases.
He's sitting at the end of a long table,
you know,
with his elbows on the table and all fingertips touching each other.
And uh,
how do you plan to make my dick some money this week?
Anyway,
so he goes,
so I asked if he was okay with it.
His eyes started getting all watery and face got red and that vein in the
forehead starts popping.
He says it fucks him up every time he thinks about it.
But it also turned him onto a whole different level.
I asked what the,
he still want to be married to her.
He said he doesn't know and excused himself.
Okay.
I asked what her vision behind this whole shit was.
And apparently she takes pleasure to see him jealous and can't do anything about
it.
She likes the whole watching him,
watching her,
her being fucked by a man or a woman.
She doesn't want to hurt him.
So she lets him in on the action.
But she loves this swinging type of shit a lot more.
Oh my God.
So wait a minute,
see,
you did it
right dude.
You,
you're writing,
you're leaving out words here and you make an a dumb guy sound even worse here
may go back about a week later,
chicken invited me to the house to prepare a presentation and I asked to do it
if he was okay with everything that happened,
all my fault.
I read it wrong or I wasn't listening my,
as I was talking because I was so nervous about fucking up the next sentence.
Oh my God,
dude,
what the fuck is wrong with you that you went back?
You know,
like you're doing some followup survey.
This whole thing is weird.
So when he goes,
well,
let's just say things were awesome in my shoes,
but I felt a little bad that they broke up.
Dude,
you know what you did?
You just saved a fucking soul.
The soul that the two of them were going to fucking make.
Okay,
that's so we'll go into a fucking different person.
I don't,
I don't know how it works.
I'm not a religious guy,
but yeah,
you just stopped a kid from being brought into the world by a,
by a couple of fucking people who need to go to therapy,
I think.
I guess I'm judging.
I don't know what those aren't parents.
Anyways,
funny thing is he still come,
he still goes over to fucker and another partner sometimes even another couple
partners swapping thing.
Basically swinger fuck buddies.
Oh yeah.
Well,
you open Pandora's box now.
No Pun intended.
Now it's no biggie.
Damn.
He goes,
I wouldn't call them freaks.
They're awesome people,
but this type of shit doesn't usually work out for the best and relationships,
let alone a marriage,
excuse my bad grammar and poor descriptive skills.
Well,
you know what?
You should have started your email with that.
So everyone wouldn't think that it was me.
Wow,
man.
I've never been involved in any,
any shit like that.
I never had a threesome or anything.
I think I could've had to,
I'd said this before,
one of them.
I was so young and stupid.
I was actually annoyed with the other girl going,
why won't she fucking leave so I can bang her friend?
You know,
I didn't get that she was lingering around.
Uh,
that one kills me because they both fucking great looking.
And then the other one was,
was a layup,
but one was fucking gorgeous and the other one looked like a god damn
refrigerator.
She was like fucking six to one of those rich people refrigerators.
You know what I mean?
That's just built into the fucking wall.
That's what she looked like.
And it's just like,
I,
you know,
I would need one of those,
like some rock climbing shit.
Take fucking handle that one.
So I gracefully bowed out of that.
Um,
yeah,
that's,
that's an an entire,
let me ask you this,
sir.
Do you live in Atlanta?
I always get that fucking freak vibe in Atlanta.
Anyways,
here we go.
Philosophy workshop.
I'm doing F,
uh,
philosophy workshop this summer called rape jokes and other offensive,
what is with all these fucking babbling about rape jokes.
I swear to fucking Christ.
I go to comedy clubs all the time.
Like you making it seem like every five seconds somebody talks about it,
you know,
he's fucking idiot bloggers.
Blogging about what kind of fucking Joe do you understand how fucking dumb that
is?
That's like if you played guitar and you start blogging about what chords people
should and shouldn't use.
Good fucking little.
It's,
it's,
it's not even frustrating.
It's just,
it's bizarre.
It's really bizarre and I've yet to see anybody,
I dunno,
anybody that's kind of doing anything or who's considered funny that's really
don't want to around telling people what they should talk about.
I would say,
why don't you work on your own act?
Okay.
You know,
you don't like rape jokes.
Don't do any,
I don't like country music.
I would never say don't do fucking country music.
It's bizarre.
The whole fucking,
it's the whole thing is just fucking,
you know,
I'm going to stop talking about this because I'm just going to add fuel to the
fire.
Um,
let's just blow through these dumb questions here.
Can people be inappropriately offended?
If so,
how do we draw the line between a pro?
This is so fucking stupid.
Don't go to a comedy club.
Oh my God.
I went to the pool and I got wet.
Is there a way to make the pool dryer,
um,
how wet is too wet,
is being offended or moral response?
If,
what kind of response,
if you're morally wrong,
someone is appropriate for you to feel guilt.
Who is,
it's just one of these bloggers who wrote this.
I find that whole thing unbelievably childish and silly.
I'm not even going to get even any fucking time of day.
Yeah.
What about chickens?
What about the chickens who died when you're talking about eating a chicken BLT.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Uh,
met girl last week of school.
Hey Bill.
This past weekend I made out with this girl I've been talking to with school
since then.
We've been talking nonstop and I really like her and I think she likes me.
Oh,
is it?
This is nice,
but in a little more than a week we will both be graduating.
She lives in Philly and I live right outside of New York.
Well you can kiss that pussy goodbye.
Sorry.
That was me.
All right.
She's really cool and different than all the other girls at school.
I'm just wondering what you think I should do.
This upcoming week is senior senior week.
You know what?
I shouldn't have said that you actually liked this girl.
I apologize.
I'm an idiot.
Um,
this up,
I'm going to treat it with respect for the rest of this.
Okay.
For the rest of this fucking email.
Um,
this upcoming week is senior week,
a week full of drinking and nonstop partying until graduation.
I know we're going to be hanging out all weekend.
I just want to get your thoughts on what I should do after graduation.
I really liked her.
She's pretty smart and isn't a lot of the same stuff I am.
Any who,
thanks for everything big fanny of you and the podcast.
And I just watched standup guys.
Hilarious.
Oh,
thank you.
Uh,
that sound you make when you get shot made me laugh so hard.
Yeah.
Got Shot there.
You're not going to make a graceful noise.
Um,
all right.
Where,
where are we going here?
What do we do it,
you know what?
You're at that time when your life where you have to figure this shit out.
Um,
you can't ask.
Someone is old and is jaded,
is made because you heard what I said right out of the,
out of the gate.
It was fucking insensitive and it was mean.
And it had nothing to do with you or the wonderful woman that you're dating.
It had to do with me and the train wreck of my fucking dating career.
All right,
so there's your lesson.
Is your lesson something that I learned,
uh,
top Papa taught me this one.
Anytime he said,
anytime we make a big decision in my life and I tell people about it,
I realized that most of the time their reaction has nothing to do with what I'm
doing.
It has everything to do with them.
So I say,
look,
if you liked this girl,
okay.
You know it's the long distance thing is really hard.
You're going to go to the both going are you guys are both going at different
colleges.
I mean it's like a fucking nightclub and just all these single people,
bye call.
You're never going to be in a greater nightclub than college.
And it's just a shame that when you're going through it,
you don't realize it.
It's just you have the pick of the litter.
You know?
The problem is is you're,
you're,
I dunno you,
you want all these experiences,
you're just getting out from underneath your parents.
They should really have college.
Like when you're 25 26 all right.
And just make it illegal to get married until then,
you know,
it just kind of have a good time figuring out what the fuck you want.
Then you go to college and he got these year pick up all these fucking people.
Maybe not 26 by then.
You're a little bit,
I dunno,
it's just everybody kind of in the prime of their life.
Okay.
Before they get jaded and that type of shit.
So I w you know what I would do,
sir?
I would follow your heart.
That's my advice.
And I wouldn't listen to old,
grizzled asshole like myself.
All right,
good luck to you.
I hope it all works out.
Um,
yeah,
you follow your heart.
You'll never be wrong.
You can still get hurt,
but you're not wrong because everybody hurts.
Sorry,
I'm wife is getting heavy.
Oh,
Jesus.
Dare BuildCo
first.
Uh,
Shit.
I didn't get that.
That's fucking hilarious.
I didn't,
I read it and it didn't make sense to look.
Came out of my mind.
Saw Doe doe like Dole would dare.
I was like,
what is he calling me?
A fucking Bambi or something.
I didn't get it.
Oh my God.
That's fucking funny.
Um,
I love the podcast.
You stay,
the,
the best guests are Rogan,
Yada,
Yada.
Right?
I'm a 26 year old fellow from Maine due to tie the knot in October with my lady
of seven years and we have a great relationship and a very happy what?
Congratulations,
sir.
You've hit the lottery.
You live in God's country.
You know,
you got yourself a great woman,
you got a great start here.
Where is the left turn coming?
Everybody?
Let's continue reading.
She's smart and it didn't take shit from no one.
She is,
uh,
stuck with me,
supported me through my oxy,
caught in addiction of course.
Fucking made,
you know what I was going to do.
I had a small part in a movie.
I was good.
It was going to do something called blue potato last September and it didn't,
the dates didn't end up working out and it was all about the oxy problem up
there in Maine.
Um,
so look for that movie because the fucking script was great.
There you go.
There's a little inside Hollywood shit.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
she helped me get through my,
through helped me get throughout what my mom died.
Yeah.
All right.
This guy did some oxy and when he was doing the oxy,
he did not take a spelling class.
All right,
let's,
let's back up here.
Help me get through.
When my mom died,
she's stuck with me.
It helped me raise and support my niece from the time she was born til present.
Oh yeah,
this girl's a champ.
Okay.
My niece is now almost four and now helping me support be jumping back and forth
here,
sir.
So now this wonderful woman,
we're going to help you out here.
He's now helping me support my father who can't work due to him dying with
multiple melanoma marrow cancer,
bone marrow cancer.
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
not melanoma.
Myeloma bone cancer.
I don't know how to read that word,
sir.
Oh Jesus.
They'll just get to the end of this fucking thing so we can all stop staring
awkwardly down at our pen and pencil set.
Okay guys,
here we go.
All of this while holding a full time job and going to college to be a
psychological nurse.
Psychological nurse.
Okay.
A bill.
She is an angel and I don't know what I would do without it,
but I have one little problem over the last few years she's been putting on the
pounds.
She loves to eat.
I,
dude,
I read in the beginning of this wife is getting heavy and I'm like,
where's the left turn?
I have the memory of a fucking ant
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
stop talking on the cell phone.
Anyways.
Yeah,
she's been putting out the pound.
She loves to eat.
I guess she stresses out with everything,
but she's gained a lot of weight in the last three years.
I'm talking at least 80 pounds.
Don't you can't have that.
Can't have that 80 pounds.
I mean,
she's almost morbidly obese.
A hundred pounds is like morbidly obese.
30 pounds is obese,
so she's going to fucking die.
Uh,
anyways,
he's go.
It got to the point where she almost weighed more than me and I'm not a small
guy,
six feet to 40 but in,
in shape for the most part,
I've got at least five inches height on her and only way 10 to 15 pounds more
than her.
I'm not,
it's not making me not want to tie the knot with her,
but if we're going to do it for the long haul,
I don't want it to have a heart attack at the age of 40.
How do I bring this up?
Because as all men,
no,
you don't bring up a woman's weight.
Uh,
helped me dollar dollar bills.
All right.
I'll tell you,
this is how you do it.
You need to lose weight,
right?
All right?
How do you do this?
What you got to do is you bring her into the fold by talking about your own
shortcomings with you.
You,
you know,
whatever weight problem you have,
because what you just six feet to 40,
you know,
till you could stand to lose a good 25 30 yourself,
get down to that to 15 to 10.
You know,
you guys are getting married.
Just say,
you know what?
Let's fucking,
uh,
you know,
watch one of those late night.
Thanks.
And just get her into it.
You know,
what is what you do first.
I got it.
This is what I would do with her.
Uh,
you've got all your,
you're living up there in Maine.
It's absolutely gorgeous.
Just say you want to take her on a picnic.
She likes food.
All right,
well you don't say,
is this going to be a mile long hike?
Oh,
it's geoboards a picnic basket and he got Brussels sprouts in there right now.
You can't do it like that.
But I,
I would start enjoying the outdoors more and I would get into some activities.
And what I would do is I'm
just slowly,
if you guys are living together,
just start introducing healthier fucking foods into the fridge and the cabinets
and toss and other shit.
And I'm just see how that works.
And if she calls you on it,
you just got to come clean.
Just say,
honey,
I love you to death.
You're the woman of my dreams.
I want to marry you.
And the last thing I ever want to do is hurt you.
And I just don't know how to bring up then I'm concerned that I'm going to lose
you.
And she'll be like,
what are you talking about?
And if you just bring it up at the fact that you concern that you're going to
lose her someday,
um,
and you bring it into the weight thing and then when she cries or whatever,
blah,
blah holder,
tell her you love her and just say,
listen,
I got to lose some weight too.
You helped me through the oxy thing.
All right,
to the point,
I'm kind of paunchy right now.
Let's,
let's get our weight down for these kids we don't have yet.
You know,
just do that.
Try that.
I'll see.
See how that fucking works.
And if it blows up in your face,
I apologize.
But I got to tell you that,
that,
that hiking thinks a little sneaky,
you know,
start going for walks.
If you hold their hand,
they don't notice that they're hiking,
you know,
that's what you do.
Hold her hand and hold her hand and then have,
have a guitar that you go fucking acoustic guitar,
you gotta thrown around your back,
like you're going to serenade her.
And she would just be so blown away.
She won't notice it.
You walk three miles up a mountain,
you know,
and then when you get up there,
you just,
you sing that the bear went over and I'm out
and all that ain't could say
I'm sorry girlfriend going to Vegas alone.
Oh God.
Okay.
Oh,
it's Joe to Rosa says you hate to see it.
Ah,
you hate to see it.
I got to have him.
I'm going to be getting one in New York next week.
I should have on the podcast next week.
I should really do that.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna reach out to Joe.
You know,
I'm actually gonna reach out to his people and see if they can get in touch with
Joe.
He's just finishing the European leg of his latest,
uh,
his latest CD.
Smash it.
What was it called?
Something personal,
I believe is what he put it out as anyways,
my girlfriend of two years and I have a great relationship.
We're in our thirties and get along better than anyone I've dated before.
I have no complaints.
You guys always start the shit like guys go,
is this like a fucking lover?
She's fucking gray.
But you know,
she has a Dick.
All right.
He goes,
I have no complaint with the way things are going.
Neither of us are looking at marriage in the future.
She's divorced.
It doesn't want to try again.
And I've never intended to get married.
Well then what?
You guys are fuck buddies.
He goes,
we just enjoy each other's company and I couldn't be happy with her.
Here's the thing,
she still gets the urge to go out and dance to blow off some steam sometime,
but I avoid it.
It's not that I don't know how to dance,
but let's just say that I partied my way through college and in Marsing myself
in that scene again only gets me into trouble with those mood enhancing
substances.
Uh,
she's got a great job and I'm like,
we can afford to go on a little vacation.
She picked Vegas and no,
I'm not the least bit worried about her banging some other dude.
She's into the ladies.
Oh,
she is.
And has an unwavering per and as my unwavering permission to go out and have her
fun with them.
As long as she's safe about it.
The threesome has always been on the table in the past,
but I honestly think I'd opt out just so we don't have the potential for a
jealousy to show its face in our relationship.
Yes,
that's a smart move.
Watching is good enough for me.
Uh,
anyway,
back to the issue at hand.
I have no issues with her going,
but I'm worried that I'm not fulfilled,
fulfilling her need to go out and party.
That's what I was going to say.
Um,
I was actually gonna suggest that he said,
okay,
let me go back here.
I'm not fulfilling your need to go out and party at the club every so often and
don't want it to build into a serious problem.
She doesn't go clubbing on the regular.
This is her first time doing anything like this since we started dating.
Do I need to grow the fuck up,
put my past behind me and start taking my lady out to the club or I just let her
keep going out on our own.
I think it's perfectly normal for two people in relationship to have activities
that they do on their own.
I'm into outdoor sports that she gets.
She's into going dancing.
We both need our adrenaline source,
uh,
outside of our great sex life together.
She says she's not planning on hooking up with a lady while she's out there.
And I wouldn't care either way,
but I am setting my,
but am I setting myself up for failure in the future?
Not taking her out myself or do I just let her go and let her have her fun?
Uh,
I would tell what you told me.
Just say,
listen,
I did the party scene in college in College.
No,
start with saying like,
listen,
I'm worried that because they don't take you out dancing eventually that's going
to lead to x,
y,
and Z.
Um,
and I have to tell you that the reason why I take you out,
it's not because the reason I don't take you,
I was not because I don't want to take you out.
It's because I did the college partying scene and I'm worried that if I go into
that scene again,
I'm getting getting in trouble with,
you know,
whatever drugs you were using,
so much of this relationship shit is just fucking taking a deep breath and just
saying,
you know,
saying why you're doing whatever the fuck it is that you're doing.
And uh,
you know,
you can't fuck with honesty.
I mean you can be upset by it.
I want to fuck your friend there.
It's out there.
All right,
here we go.
Third break.
Oh my God.
Hour and 15 minutes.
You guys got your money's worth,
Huh?
Here we go.
Personal capital,
everybody.
Two things suck about managing your money.
It's hard to keep track of.
You got stocks,
bonds,
four o one k IRA,
bank accounts,
et cetera.
All on different sites with their own username and password.
They literally just described my financial situation and every month I get like
19 statements and I look at them and I rubbed my chin and I can't tell which end
is up.
So anyways,
they say here,
then you pay someone to manage it.
And you're probably paying too much.
All right.
That's why you got to love personal capital.
It takes under a minute to set this up.
Just go to the podcast page on billboard.com and click the personal capital
banner.
Then you can see your whole net worth and how each asset is performing on one
screen,
on your computer or through their app on your phone or tablet.
It doesn't get easier than that.
Then it shows you how much you're paying money managers and brokers and fees and
how you can reduce those fees and even gives you specific areas where you can
improve your investment strategies.
So in other words,
the entire operation is transparent the exact way you want it to be when you're
dealing with your money and this thing is really is a really smart way to grow
you and make your,
excuse me,
this is thing is a really smart way to make your money make,
oh,
this is a typo here.
This thing is a really smart way to make your money grow quicker.
It's one by former,
the former CEO of paypal,
and it's totally free to sign up for free.
Go to the podcast page on billboard.com and click on the personal capital
banner.
There you were.
And finally,
Father's day is around the corner.
What does that mean?
This father's Day?
What are you going to be thinking?
You've got to think the man.
Great.
What is the main gray you ask?
They are 100% made in America.
Cast iron grilling greats that are revolutionizing the way people grill heavy
duty grilling greats.
Deliver exactly what you need to achieve that perfect steak flavor.
Um,
chicken,
steak or veggies.
We'll never have tasted so good.
You know the deal,
you go out,
you buy your favorite grill,
everything's cool.
You got the gas,
you've got the charcoal,
whatever you want to use.
But then they give you those little wimpy,
that little wimpy,
great.
You know,
it's like a bunch of pretzel rods welded together.
This gives you,
this looks like those stakeout once the steakhouse ones,
you know the uh,
well,
I'll read more about it here.
No more flare ups.
No more dry meat.
Guaranteed named one of 2012 best grilling Cesarea by men's health magazine.
Man Grades are perfect or the perfect gift for dad this father's Day.
Go to man,
great.com and enter the coupon code burr for their 1999 father's day special or
click the man great banner on the website.
100% made in America,
100% cast iron,
100% percent steak house quality grilling in your backyard.
I've got to tell you,
I actually use something like this.
Uh,
I got the giant egg.
You're going reason why I didn't do the man grades because they don't have one
big enough for it,
but it's the exact same kind of thing.
It makes all the difference in the world and up telling you that you're not
going to go wrong with this and your dad,
he's going to break down and cry and hug you.
And if he doesn't,
then I don't know what.
I don't know what to tell you.
Okay?
Remember each Monday morning podcast or it comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush.
Again,
that's demand.
Great Grill enhancement system order today,
man.
great.com,
man,
greg.com and enter the coupon code burpee.
You are are at the checkout.
All right,
well that's the podcast this week.
Everybody.
Um,
I hope you guys have been enjoying the NHL playoffs.
I know I talk about him a lot,
but,
uh,
they're really starting to get great.
I haven't watched any of the,
uh,
out the west,
but,
uh,
I love what the La Kings are doing.
There's nothing I love seeing better than when when a,
when a team that knows how to win just,
just,
just flips the switch.
It's,
it's a,
it's an incredible thing to watch.
It really is.
I haven't been,
haven't been watching it,
but I've been watching the results of their games.
The fucking guys do.
What do they do?
They lost two to one,
a road of the blues then came back when the last four,
they won the first two against,
uh,
the shots in and the sharks won in overtime.
But,
um,
that's my dark horse,
uh,
out west for taking out the,
you know,
the winner of the Black Hawks red winks.
Obviously the favorite is the black hawks.
He got to,
the kings are a very,
very dangerous tape and I'm obviously loving how the Bruins are playing,
but I got to tell you,
the penguins have so much talent,
but the goaltending is shaky.
That's their Achilles heel there,
you know?
And you know why they still have Achilles heel because Matt Cook plays for him.
So he didn't slice it off with his skate accidentally.
Oh,
by the way,
Phil Jackson,
I got to gloat here.
It's a little gloating moment.
At the end of the podcast,
Phil Jackson wrote a book and at some interesting things to say,
Colby.
So I just want to ask Laker fans,
uh,
is he,
is he also a hater?
He won five championships with that guy.
You know,
and if you read between the lines of what Phil Jackson writes in his book about
Colby,
all right,
you'll basically have exactly what the fuck I've been saying.
All right,
so there you go.
I fucking called it just like Paul Versey.
Ah,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
Once again,
thank you to everybody who came out to the Mirage a casino and thank you to the
Mirage casino and everybody out in Vegas.
That really was a dream come true.
And to perform at such a legendary casino and have all those people come out and
got treated like a fucking king there.
And we're actually hoping that that's going to be my home base.
And I can come out there because of the turnover,
because every day,
I don't know,
100,000,
200,000 people leave on.
Now the 200,000 come in.
Um,
I'm really hoping that,
um,
that can become my home away from home.
That's what we're going to be working towards.
So,
uh,
so that is it for the podcast as always,
amazon.com banner on.
If you want to donate to this podcast,
you just go to [inaudible] dot com click on the podcast page and just click on
the Amazon banner and a,
it brings you right to Amazon.
Whatever you buy,
they kicked me a portion,
doesn't cost you any money.
They kicked me a little juice.
I take part of that and I throw it to the wounded warriors project.
So you support me and you support in the,
uh,
all the heroes who've come back,
for fighting these wars here.
And a,
and last but not least,
we have a,
the download of my latest special you people all the same digital or if you want
a hard copy DVD,
um,
you can get them right off bill bird.com.
That's it.
Hope you guys have a great week.
Go Fuck Yourself.
And also now that the show is over,
go also go set up your free trial of the voice so you can start making more
money.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and use your Promo Code Bill.
That's Eva [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Ville.
Or just go to the podcast page on [inaudible] dot com and click the voice banner
right now,
ladies and gentlemen.
Now that the show is over,
go sign up for your free account with personal capital so you can see all of
your assets on one screen.
Pay Less broker,
pay less than broker fees and make all your investments grow faster.
Go to the podcast page on [inaudible] dot com click on the personal capital
banners.
That's the podcast page on billboard.com to click on the personal capital banner
and set up your free account.